>> ON IT'S WAY OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION LEFT BEHIND A LOT
OF OF AMERICANS AND FEARLY
$90 BILLION IN MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
HOW MUCH IS THAT?
ONLY TWO COUNTRIES ON THE PLANET
HAVE A MILITARY BUDGET LARGER,
CHINA AND THE UNITED STATES.
THE TALIBAN HAS THE BEST
EQUIPPED MILITARY OF IT'S SIZE
IN THE WORLD.
THE TALIBAN RECEIVED MORE THAN
22,000 HUMVEES.
50,000 TRUCKS AND ARMORED
VEHICLES AND A SIZABLE AIRFORCE
WITH FOUR C130 TRANSPORT PLANES,
DOZENS OF FIXED WING AIRCRAFT.
350 COMBAT HELICOPTERS.
THE TALIBAN HAS MORE BLACK HAWKS
THAN MANY DEVELOPED NATION -DZ.
SOLDIERS GOT MORE THAN 350,000
AMERICAN RIFLES.
HAND GUNS AND APPROXIMATELY
61,000 HEAVY MACHINE GUNS.
QUITE AN ARSENAL OUGHT YOUR
EXPENSE.
A DISASTER OBVIOUSLY.
IT MAKES FOR A STRIKING CONTRAST
OF THIS COUNTRY.
AT THE VERY MOMENT THE WHITE
HOUSE IS ARMING OUR NEW FRIENDS
THE TALIBAN AND THEY'RE WORKING
HARD TO DISARM YOU.
WHETHER IT MAKES THE NEWS IT'S
HAPPENING.
THE ADMINISTRATION JUST
ANNOUNCED QUIETLY IT'S BANNING
SOME OF THE MOST COMMONLY
PURCHASED AMMUNITION IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS WILL END INTENTIONALLY,
LEAD TO SEVERE SHORT APBLZ IN
THE COUNTRY.
JOE BIDEN HAS SAID HE WOULD LIKE
TO PREVENT YOU FROM OWNING THE
FIREARMS MOST AMERICANS USE TO
DEFEND THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
THE -FRTS ARE NOW ACCELERATED.
HOW ABOUT THAT AN ANSWER, NO.
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO GIVE MORE
THAN HALF A MILLION GUNS TO THE
TALIBAN, GUNS WE PAID FOR AND
TAKE OUR GUNS AWAY IN THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT'S NOT HOW IT WORKS.
SHUT UP AND BACK OFF.
NOT ONE MORE WORD ABOUT GUN
CONTROL FROM THESE PEOPLE UNTIL